new scenes of anarchy in liberal cities
as criminals get a free pass to
viciously beat up cops a 16-year-old
arrested after this nasty brawl with an
nypd officer inside a subway station
after being stopped for not paying the
fare the teen repeatedly punching the
officer over and over again then
wrestling him to the ground and putting
the officer in a choke hold that suspect
was later charged with assault and
resisting arrest but you can probably
guess what happened next just hours
later he was back out on the street and
that is despite the fact that the teen
has been busted twice before for robbery
and gun possession a former cop telling
jesse this is a direct result of the
left's constant anti-police rhetoric
now could you imagine if this cop felt
so in fear of his life he had to use
that weapon there would now be riots in
the street a cop now has to worry about
getting arrested
losing his job and getting sued civilly
so while they're concentrating on that
they very well may lose their lives and
mayor eric adams also reacting and
blaming ridiculous no cash fail laws
catch
release
repeat
catch release repeat this person was
arrested for robbery a few days ago now
he's back as soon as we catch them
the system releases them
and they repeat the action
that is just you know that's when i say
we're the laughingstock of the country
this is what i'm talking about
how do we keep our cities safe when the
other parts of the criminal justice
system
they have abandoned
our public safety apparatus
how do we keep our city safe
when the other part of the system has
abandoned the apparatus you know what
he's talking about he's talking about
the democrats in albany who will not
allow the repeal of the cashless bail
law you see that's why i criticize the
man he talks the talk but he will not
walk the walk call out hokel who's
running andrea stewart cousins and carl
he's in albany that's all it takes he is
not criticizing cashless bail he's not
criticizing it greg until he says
you three people are responsible yeah
you know i i love also how they blur the
perp's face
i mean oh
we don't want to we don't want to get
you know we don't want to violate his
privacy as he's trying to choke out a
cop in the days of old the logic was a
person who would attack a police officer
is very dangerous because that means
they would do far worse to a non-police
officer but it's it's amazing how
quickly decline can come when you accept
decline it's like when somebody decides
to stop being physically fit and just
lets everything go that's what's
happening to the city people in the in
the criminal justice system it's it's
just letting go all there are no more
standards now imagine being that cop
okay it's a high-risk job and it's going
to get rough and in the fog of war you
have to make a dozen decisions maybe 100
decisions split second and what do you
have around you a dozen gawkers with
phones while you in this in this fog of
war have to think like what if i make a
mistake my career is over do i punch
this guy do i do a chokehold do i tase
him where's my you know where you know
and meanwhile the people filming you
they're not lifting a finger because
this is just interesting stuff that that
we use i think it is time
to cease our obsession on law
enforcement encounters because what we
always see
is the last moment between the
trajectory of a criminal and the cop
that his job is there to stop the
criminal we don't see the criminal's
path that got there so we're sitting
there monday morning quarterbacking
doesn't even matter if it's one of these
encounters but even school shootings
we're only there to see that final bam
when the cop meets the criminal we don't
know anything else that happened how
that guy got there it's like showing up
the movie to see the climax and then we
blame one side for having to deal with
our society has abdicated what led to
that why was that kid out of prison why
was that how the kid had a loaded weapon
and he was still let out these are all
those steps that nobody dare talk about
because they focus on this video and
then this leads to law enforcement
controversies and failures and perhaps
riots if it appears that the cop acted
too much so they can't win because all
we're left with is this
anyway
okay katie
this kid
had two priors okay he had a loaded
weapon he had a crossbow we're talking
robbery
uh this this 16 year old but for him to
react with the violence that he reacted
with
for a turnstile
berating the police officer before he
even put him in a chokehold before he
punched him 12 times threw him into a
great that is hate there's no reason to
do that for a low level crime he's
jumping return style what's the problem
a basic thing like paying the fee for a
metro ticket for a subway ticket this is
the way that he reacts now the left
would say that there are reasons why he
acted this way and maybe some
justifications in his background for the
reason why he committed the priors and
also got so angry when it came to the
police simply saying you can't jump the
term style you need to pay for your
ticket
there's been a lot of tolerance over the
past three years of criminal behavior
and not just petty theft which leads to
bigger crimes but of violent behavior
and because the left has completely
villainized the broken windows theory
which prevents things like this from
happening take care of the little stuff
so it doesn't become big stuff we're now
in this predicament where the cops are
engaging in violent encounters pretty
much any time they try to stop somebody
there was a hearing on capitol hill
today in the senate judiciary committee
and they were going through all the
statistics on police murders this year
how they're set for another record one
of the things they mentioned too was
that the resisting arrest and suspects
running from police are at an all-time
high so that immediately ramps up the
temperature goes to the issue of police
wanting trying to hesitate and overthink
what they're doing and trying to stop a
threat and it turns violent almost
immediately and the officers who
testified said look
we can get all the resources that we we
need from you in terms of money but if
we don't think that you have our back we
can't do our job and that's where this
has led to you know jesse mayor adams
said that he wants a special session of
the legislature the new york state
legislature along with the gop who has
called for that not to deal with
cashless bail okay which is the crux of
the problem but because of the supreme
court's decision in bruin which would
allow people to carry weapons who have
legal weapons and the spiraling crime he
wants to revisit that issue
well
maybe you could do that second but i
think cash bail is the real issue and if
he did that and put pressure on the
legislature and the governor the new
york post would be behind him local fox
5 all the locals all the papers
and they would buckle i believe so a
little advice to the mayor when the
police officer is squaring up with a
suspect like that his goal is to take
the guy down and arrest him the the
suspect's goal is to escape or land
punches
so the police officer has to maintain
his grip and if you've noticed he's not
putting him in a side
uh headlock he's not doing the under
headlock and he's not doing the choke
because those things have been outlawed
right he's also not shooting for a leg
takedown because that exposes your
firearm to the guy's arm right here so
he's very limited in what he's able to
do physically you know the cop can fight
because he's got good balance he threw a
nasty elbow when the guy was up against
the wall and he landed a nice overhand
right hand but he ate a lot of punches
so you got to be thinking to yourself if
the cameras weren't there and he was
allowed to use these skills this
probably would have been over because
the cop looks like he has about 50
pounds on the guy and where is the taser
the
police officer's partner should have
used a taser i don't know where she was
there and
this guy knows the law judge because
he's already had a gun charge and if
you're in school remember think about it
in school if you know you're not going
to get suspended or expelled for dealing
drugs for fighting for cheating you're
going to do all those things if you know
it's only a demerit and the gangs know
the law too so they're going to give
this teenager a firearm because they
don't want to catch a felony charge with
a gun so they'll give it to the
teenagers they're way ahead of the
legislature so until the legislator
wakes up and figures out we need to
start trying to lock up criminals and
sort of instead of depopulating the
prison system
that's their goal depopulating the
prison system they got to get rid of
that idea then we can start fighting
crime
what do you think jessica
well i think that his partner was trying
to make a valiant effort he had a female
partner it looks like who was being
attacked by i assume someone who was
there with the person
so
she was doing the best that she could
and i kept thinking while watching this
first of all get off your phone and help
i think that they're for everyone who's
recording these kinds of incidents
there's a lot i'm not saying that you
just throw yourself every time into the
fire here but if there are a bunch of
people in that subway station and you
can all at least gesture towards trying
to help maybe you could have saved a lot
of trouble um for the folks there i
think there is a major misconception um
from people who are sitting in the
capitals of these states or the people
are in charge of the reform or what
could be making reforms with what voters
on the ground think and if you just did
a simple focus group of the voters that
you think are your main supporters they
may still say i would still re-elect you
because i x y and z reasons but nobody
likes this there is not one person that
i know i have the most liberal cohort of
friends i would say new york city
liberals that even some of them who were
supportive of get uh voting for alvin
bragg for instance and everyone is
petrified of this and i keep thinking
back to that case you remember a couple
years ago there was a police officer in
ohio who broke up a fight between two
teenage girls and ended up killing one
of the girls and the country erupted
about it and lebron james weighed in on
it and it turned into this horrible
scene where this officer must have been
completely petrified for his life in the
future of his career being able to
support his family and he was cleared of
the charges because he was doing the
right thing and saved the other 16 year
old girl from this and i can't imagine
how scary it is and nothing in the
background of this kid who had already
been charged with you know various
offenses i think equals
the damage that we are doing right now
to our health and public safety and i
think adams was actually calling out
cashless bail it does not bother me that
in this speech he didn't say kathy hokel
but people know how it works yeah you
can't yes you said it when
when someone does something that is even
90 of what you want you have to you do
you have enough okay that's not enough
he runs the city it's not enough people
are dying because he's being political i
went on brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now